support for big thing comes from
Microsoft delivering people ready
enterprise solutions designed to help
companies do more with less details at
Microsoft comm slash people ready
I'm Alice Rivlin and I'm a senior fellow
at the Brookings Institution
I think we're in a positive innovation
cycle which is definitely not over there
are lots of things happening in new
electronic applications in new
healthcare applications and that's going
to power our economy going forward it is
not a moment at which I think anyone can
say we've run out of ideas at the moment
we've run out of credit no we aren't
financing people's new ideas but we need
to turn that around
there's certainly risks of not investing
in technology there are bigger risks of
investing in the wrong technology the
landscape is littered with corporations
and government agencies that revamp
their computer systems quickly and
caused more chaos than the advantage of
investing in new technology so the
bottom line is got to do it very
carefully and have some very skilled
people doing it
computers and telecommunications have
revolutionized our the way we conduct
business and the way we conduct our
lives the problems are that we're
overwhelmed with too much information
and too much noise going on I think the
the real problem of surviving these
wonderful innovations is to keep a bit
centered to this matters for business it
matters for ordinary people and not get
overwhelmed and distracted by the
rapidity and the volume of the
information flow
technology is helping the government a
lot and could help more basically a lot
of things go more smoothly the
government is involved in huge
information collection operations it
essentially runs huge insurance
companies called Social Security a lot
of information needs to be collected and
processed quickly
that's certainly changed the way the
government operates one of the agencies
that has had most benefit but also most
trouble in getting into the modern
computer age is the Internal Revenue
Service taxes are certainly processed
more quickly and efficiently than they
used to be but there's a long way to go
in improving those community computer
systems the technology has also given
average people more access to government
information and and help you can go on
lots of websites and find out what's
available to help your particular
business or help you as a taxpayer on a
particular problem there's a long way to
go but both the federal government and
state and local governments are much
more effective than they used to be
because they have taken advantage of
modern technology
most major government agencies have a
chief technology officer and ought to
have most states and cities do as well
they clearly technology is extremely
important to the functioning of any
large organization whether it's a
corporation or a government agency and
somebody very highly qualified has to be
in charge support for big thing comes
from Microsoft delivering people ready
enterprise solutions designed to help
companies do more with less details at
Microsoft comm slash people ready